[Musique]
10 000 livres sur NE Bonapart 10, c'est
plus que n'importe qui dans l'histoire, donc vous
n'allez pas lire 10 000 livres donc vous
allez probablement choisir des
événements historiques qui sont factuels, mais
quand a été le premier livre, peut-être 5 ans
plus tard  qui prendrait la peine d'écrire un livre
à ce moment-là si tôt, cela aurait pu être
20 ans plus tard, donc il y a déjà beaucoup
de spéculations sur les faits, ce qui
lui est arrivé on sine, etc.,
au moment où vous obtenez un millier de livres dans lesquels vous êtes
spéculation sérieuse, donc notre travail
est de prendre en compte tout ce que nous
savons et de le mettre dans un
objectif concis, mais surtout, mettre l'
accent sur le
personnage de Bonapart est une pièce très historique
qui pourrait facilement être considérée comme
une leçon d'histoire.  Ce n'est pas intéressant de voir
à quel point les gens ont peur d'apprendre
quelque chose de merde, alors oui, tous ces
films de super-héros qui sont aussi stupides qu'ils
peuvent l'être, où il s'agit plus des événements
que des gens réels, c'est avant tout une question d'
effets spéciaux, pas de gens, donc je vais devoir le
faire.  persuader quelqu'un de
faire ce film et je promets que ce ne sera pas
une leçon d'histoire, ce sera plus
que ça. Je pense que nous
[Musique] avons
réussi
[Musique]
le département artistique a fourni au
moins 200 vrais chevaux et 800 vrais hommes sur  de
chaque côté, les effets visuels ajouteront
ceux du fond de la ligne, mais il
faut le filmer en sachant que si je tire
comme ça, cela fait 800 hommes,
il y aura encore 4 000 hommes de cette façon,
tous se déplaçant ensemble, de la même manière que les chevaux.
pour que tout soit réglé et
parce que j'utilise et que 11 caméras, nous sommes
très
rapides et évitons
les répétitions parce que la répétition, vous pouvez vous
épuiser et vous ennuyer, d'accord, donc nous avons fait
tout le film en 61 jours 61 ouais, ça fait deux
mois ouais, alors quand tu sais  ils
ne m'ont pas donné assez de temps, je
n'ai que 15 semaines pour aller les baiser,
faire un film, c'est comme un énorme kit Lego
sur mon unité, c'est 900 membres du personnel chaque
matin, je dois y aller et dire que nous devons y aller
boum boum boum  boum et toute l'équipe
est là, prête à partir donc
quelqu'un doit dire quoi faire sinon c'est le
chaos, vous ne pouvez pas discuter de la
première position de la caméra avec vous connaissez l'
acteur, le directeur artistique, j'ai ma
première conversation le matin avec le
DP qui a la tâche monumentale de gérer un
campus 21. J'ai appris mon cinéma
dans ce que j'appelle une grande industrie appelée
publicité, il y a un moment où
la publicité était pour moi presque une forme d'art,
de grands réalisateurs français d'ailleurs
comme Mundo John Paul bon Etc.  et j'étais
de l'autre côté en Angleterre en Amérique et
donc cela a réinventé l'apparence des films,
nous influençons définitivement les films futurs sur la façon dont
ils coupent, regardent et éclairent et et à cause de
cela, j'étais caméraman, donc une fois que vous
savez comment fonctionner, vous pouvez parler à l'opérateur.
si je suis dans ma caravane comme un
box à chevaux il y a 11 caméras il y a 11
moniteurs donc chaque gars a un casque pour
parler à la caméra 1 ou à la caméra 6 tu as
raté la photo tu as été trop lent à changer
d'objectif donc ça arrive toute la journée c'est
technique  mais c'est aussi euh c'est très
artistique merci beaucoup merci
a
je suis
[Musique]
debout